[Music]
in all industrial fields, whatever
they may be,
artificial intelligence is a major challenge for
competitiveness,
it allows both to have
differentiating products but also
to do so with competitiveness and
industrial productivity at the highest
level in the  industrial field that is
the naval defense in which naval
group fits
artificial intelligence is also a
major challenge of competitiveness this on two
levels the first plan is to be able to
bring technological superiority to the
fight for all the  marines who
are our customers
the second challenge is to be able to do
this with a level of
industrial competitiveness that allows us to be at the
level of the price expected by our customers
in terms of the deadlines for
making the boats available and on our
ships the  crews will be able to
have critical systems in which they
can have full confidence because
they are reliably secure  é and robust
while integrating an
artificial intelligence capacity which
will really give them the superiority
of information and the superiority of
the commitment in the case of the program
confidence haye the stake for naval
group and to industrialize the
critical systems to  base dia which are
installed on ships or which are
used within the framework of our
production tool our group can be
fully in line with the
ali confidence program and whose seven
themes of this technological pillar
for the industrialization of  ai
naturally as a system u
integrators we will rather
work on the cases of the face of ai
in our developments of
critical systems to remove the locks
of industrialization
we will also ensure
that all the program output data
trust  price in
particular the toolbox and the
tooled methods which are going to be the
main output data of this project will
p  perfectly well integrated into the
development tools of our
j operational sky is also within
the framework of our industrial tools
another point on which we will be
particularly attentive is to
ensure that all of
the program output data trust  to
be perfectly in line with
the methodologies known as experience integration
validation verification qualification
of the operational software or
production tools that we implement
on our sites
[Music]